[Music]
it's an annual event with an audience
larger than the Super Bowl and you may
have never even heard of it I'm talking
about the Eurovision song contest the
world's largest music competition it's
been held every year since 1956 they
tell me didn't even know there was music
back then artists from 37 countries have
qualified to do battle in this week's
finals in Liverpool England and Remy
inosenso has more now on the event that
celebrates pop music and pop culture
be it Abba for the Baby Boomers
for Gen X or 2023 grammy-nominated Mona
skin
Eurovision the
competition has been a touchstone
through
Americans have still never heard of to
Americans who have never heard of
Eurovision
how do you describe it I used to say
it's like American Idol meets the
Olympics but better now I feel like I'd
have to say it is the Olympics of song
for Europe hey how are you doing Alicia
Michelle is a Eurovision YouTuber in
Washington D.C
I mean the scale is just so Grand the
fact that you might not be watching it
is crazy
crazy is also what a lot of people have
called this contest over 67 years and
1500 songs it's gone from the wacky and
tacky to the Lusty
and the thrusty
with a liberal dose of diversity and
inclusion
drawing 180 million viewers worldwide a
larger audience than the Super Bowl
going through to the final and politics
has become a part participating
countries traditionally vote favorably
for their neighbors and allies
[Applause]
and last year Ukraine's entry kalush
Orchestra won with a landslide popular
vote following Russia's invasion
this year they're represented by
producer Andrei hutsuliak and
nigerian-born frontman Jeffrey Kenny who
formed the pop duo tovorti we met them
in Kiev it was important to represent
our country the best possible way and we
hope our son can inspire people all
around the planet to be stronger and no
matter how bad it is just hold the good
attitude and move forward with the smile
their song Heart Of Steel is a message
of defiance inspired by Ukrainian
soldiers who fought to defend the
besieged city of mariupole I gotta ask
can you sing it for me sometimes just
gotta know when you stick your middle
finger up in the air
life is just a game
and I'm playing for the win Liverpool
are you ready with the war still raging
this year's contest will be hosted in
Liverpool England on Ukraine's behalf 37
countries hope to follow the footsteps
of past winners who shot to fame like
Celine Dion who won in 1988 for
Switzerland
and even interval acts like Ireland's
then unknown Riverdance in 1994.
but I think this year A lot of people
are coming you know with a
with the heat so they knew we won last
year and I'm sure they didn't want us to
win this year so it's going to be
definitely hard
[Applause]
Victory could Propel this year's winner
to stardom so they'll sing any song and
do any dance to win
for CBS mornings raymie and ascencio
London
so I mean I had never heard it so I went
to one I went to the one in 1996 in Oslo
and it's it's a it's a blast I mean it's
a what what had you heard of it Tony I
was going to say of the three of us at
this table guess who has heard of this
before not only that you know I went to
one County in 1996. WoW
Sean has heard of it too well Sean is
not at the table you are but it does
seem very cool I'd never heard of it
yeah it's a lot of fun and as you as
raymie points out I mean Abba and Celine
Dion and there have been Arts artists
that have actually become Global
phenomenas you know when they win but no
U.S people you know I don't recall uh
seeing a lot of American acts but maybe
they're there but I the time that I went
I don't remember okay Will Ferrell did a
movie about it yeah oh on Netflix yeah
it's funny all right